et salut à tous c'est françois pour
explique mans encore aujourd'hui on
apprend comment foot et un visage sur
une photo
jeudi sur une photo allez on enlève le
truc la bombe à introd
[Musique]
alors on a parfois besoin de foot et un
visage sur une photo avant publication
pour des questions de droits à l'image
et aujourd'hui on va voir comment faire
ça très simplement sur un os qu et sur
windows et non je n'ai toujours pas de
tablettes android d'ailleurs à ce propos
je suis preneur de recommandations donc
n'hésitez pas à mettre dans les
commentaires des références de tablettes
qui pourraient être intéressantes et
c'est parti pour ios première chose à
faire aller télécharger l'application
skitch qui est gratuite ensuite je vais
aller sur l'application photos de mon
ipad
sachant que ça marche sur ipad ou sur
iphone ans sans problème est ici vous
voyez que j'ai donc une personne dont je
voudrais flouter le visage je vais aller
cliquer en haut ici sur les petits
boutons de réglage est allé de cliquer
sur ces trois petits boutons ici vous
voyez que j'ai accès à des applications
dont skitch ici alors si jamais elle
apparaît pas vous avez dans votre main
et vous vérifiez bien que la case ici
est cochée donc là je vais l'accrocher
hockey et je sélectionne skitch donc
vous voyez ici que j'ai accès à gauche à
un petit élément de couleur pour choisir
les choses si je voulais écrire dessus
mais là c'est pas le cas et donc en bas
à droite de cette petite flèche sur
laquelle je vais aller taper pour ouvrir
faire dérouler les différences outils
qui sont proposés par stich je vais
aller taper sur ces petits carrés là en
haut à droite et je n'ai plus qu'à
sélectionner avec mon doigt la zone que
je veux foot est ici en l'occurrence le
visage et c'est terminé je clique sur ok
et la photo est enregistrée ce qui est
pas mal dans le fait de passer dans
l'application photos plutôt que d'aller
directement dans l'application skitch
c'est qu'on va pouvoir revenir en
arrière les modifications ne sont pas
destructive
par exemple ici si je retourne sur mes
petits réglages je clique sur revenir
revenir à l'original et ma photo et
comme elle était au départ allant voir
maintenant comment ça se passe sur un pc
alors là je vais vous montrer deux
versions une moche mais efficace et une
un peu plus joli pour la moche mais
efficace je vais simplement aller dans
l'application photo native de windows
voilà j'ai mis ma photo dans la
pellicule jeunes est importé dans photo
est ici je vais avoir la possibilité de
dessiner ici vous voyez l'onglet sur le
monde l'image donc je vais tout
simplement aller prendre ici une couleur
un noir avec un très un petit peu gros
voilà et je vais juste dessiné un sur
mon visage de cette façon il est alors
pas floutés mais il est masqué donc pour
les histoires du droit à l'image
il n'y a pas de souci ça se fait en deux
avec le stylet ou avec le doigt donc
c'est la version moche mais facile alors
pour la version un petit peu plus joli
un poil plus compliqué mais ça reste
quand même largement faisable
je vais utiliser evernote qui va me
permettre de faire exactement la même
chose que ce qu'il fait c'est parti
alors j'ai ma photo sur mon bureau je
vais la faire glisser tout simplement
dans evernote
jusque là tout va bien si je sélectionne
ma photo ici j'ai un petit à entourer
qui va être l'outil en fait de skitch
qui va permettre de faire exactement la
même chose qu'avec skitch je clique
dessus mapoto s'ouvre et là vous voyez
sur la gauche je retrouve exactement les
mêmes fonctionnalités qu avec ce kit je
vais aller cliquer ici sur pixelisé
l'image et de la même façon je vais
sélectionner ma zone on n'oublie pas un
d'enregistrer ici bien sûr est terminée
donc voilà maintenant pour récupérer ma
photo je débute la faire glisser sur le
bureau ou dans un dossier qui
m'intéresse et voilà votre visage est
complètement floutés voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo ben vous aura été utile n'hésitez
pas à me mettre dans les commentaires
d'autres façons de faire si on a des
plus simples si vous en connaissez
d'autres
et rappelez vous que si cette vidéo vous
a plu vous pouvez tout à fait mettre un
petit pouce en l'air vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne pour être sûr de ne
rien rater des prochaines vidéos et moi
je vous dis à très vite pour une
prochaine vidéo et
[Musique]
m